people like try to figure me out through  my act it's all jokes i told an abortion  joke recently and a woman approached me  she was like hey that's very insensitive  i've had an abortion you shouldn't tell  jokes like that i was like whoa hey  sorry i just told a joke i think what  you did was much worse  but you know  either way i'll see at home later honey  and again all jokes i love abortions i  paid for two last week i'm a fan right  you remember come on  it's all jokes friend of mine she works  at planned parenthood she loves that  joke and i was like i might have to get  rid of it people don't like it she's  like no no you got to keep it i was like  i might get rid of she's like no you got  to keep but i was like oh my god it's  like oh my god i was like don't tell me  to do with my body of work she's like  every joke's a miracle  but i don't want to upset anybody you  know  want to upset that's ah my intention